I was just waiting patiently because
obviously I'm listening to the guys
behind me there's a lot of things I
think you can see from my face that are
actually winding me up and I thought am
I going to take a break here or just be
polite and sit quietly because you
talked about
uh women I think the word used was
combat combative combative yeah they
were yeah that was I was sitting here
and that was winding me up constantly
the way that you and others were talking
about older women or you know could be
vice versa and older men and I was just
getting more and more angry and I
thought well just hit it quietly and see
what you've all got to say and we all
have personal opinions
but it doesn't mean that just because
you're with an older woman
that
um they are taking advantage of you and
you're just having fun how about
consider that somebody a little bit
older than you might actually be
interested in you it's not always for
fun I mean you can ask that to me
personally if I'm in getting involved
with someone
I'm not interested in fun you know I've
got
personal views self-respect I don't need
to go around dropping my pants like all
these other girls I don't need to do all
that so it doesn't matter who I date
I'm interested in something
proper I think the word is proper
something proper and not to play around
so obviously I'm not going to date you
sort of sorry yeah I just I think that's
just how guys view it like Yeah and I
don't mean any offense personally I just
think when guys typically if they date
girls that are significantly older than
them like long-term guys look at family
and they prefer to have kids of their
own and I just think over a certain age
you're kind of out of the equation no no
I totally understand that and um you
also have to take into account that a
lot of
a lot of men and women already have
children when you meet them and if you
have a good heart and you're a good
person
um you will actually embrace that and I
will be really open about that and I
will say that to anyone I meet if I meet
a man now I don't care how old you are
you know you could be a single dad
whether you're 25 45 and bringing these
kids up on your own I'm going to embrace
that
uh if I got to touch on that I like yeah
like that's I I think it's very like
correct me from I think it's very easy
for like a woman to say that but I just
feel like me I I I'm losing a lot if
I'm dating an older woman who already
has kids like that's baggage I do not
want to carry it's not baggage that's
the word that I didn't like you using
it's it's not baggage you're using
really
nothing but that's that's how men view
it and it's not it's that fun it's not
nice but it's just true all the time not
all men not women men could have baggage
too I would I would not call anything
you have baggage so I'm talking to the
guys behind me so say
um you're 20. say if right now
as a 20 year old you'd already got two
or three kids it's just how it is I
would not even though you're young and
you've had kids at an early age I would
not call that baggage why would you call
kids and life experiences baggage it's
wrong that's a woman's point of view
yeah typically because
more typically because because it
fulfills our meeting strategy because in
history like if a guy could impregnate
multiple people it showed he could take
care of them where men wanted to ensure
paternity and pass on resources to the
kids that are there so like I'm not
saying every single person and every
single guy but it's just how in general
they view it yeah
oh I was just gonna say I think we're
throwing around the world baggage too
Lucy like yeah how how is like
somebody's past experiences and their
children that they've like had from
those past experiences how is that
baggage like because if you're dating
older women you that's the probabilities
that they have a past marriage and they
have past children so if you don't want
to deal with that baggage then don't
date them and you know why but he's
saying he doesn't because that's baggage
to him and I think he should be
allowed to say that yeah you can say
that and remember men have baggage too
let me tell you the baggage that meant
Curry you know but you always like you
always you always do this whenever we
say something about women we always have
to say something we do because
why we have to be fair because the man
the older they get there's two things
we talk about men's baggage all the time
that we talk about because I don't
really hear them what are you talking
about I'm not in the media all the time
why is men are trash why is that a
common that's not baggage that's that's
a judgment the baggage that men carry if
the older they get as well means they
either been in sales for longer or
they've [ __ ] around for longer so
those two bring two problems either
you're going to be insecure and think
that you cannot trust any woman because
you've been with too many three or fours
or you're going to be very insecure in
yourself and in your manlihood because
you've not had enough experience so men
have the insecurities and they have
their baggage that's why you'd rather be
with somebody that's somewhere on your
level because it's easier for both of
you to carry this thing
I I agree with you like men what yeah
they're you agree with me yeah some men
have baggage some women have baggage but
I'm saying men and what like like men
and women don't look at children the
same and you can't change reality it
just is what it is yeah like like um
I've heard guys say they get more girls
after they have kids I've never heard a
single mother say her her dating options
got better after a child I've never
heard that like I heard I've heard guys
say they brought their kid to the park
because they know the girls would like
you know
stupidly speaking men don't want to have
to spread their resources to kids though
and it's also like they have a lot of
risk that comes with that like they have
to invest in a kid that's not theirs and
I I don't know if you have kids and I
don't know you know how old the kids are
but especially if they're young they
could raise a kid for 10 years and have
no legal rights to that child at the end
of it they've got options if they want
to be involved in the child's life
obviously it's a man's choice if they
want to be that involved and have rights
they they can legally adopt and give
their names that child or they are just
the woman's partner who has kids in
their life right and they can and I
think I think if more women would do
that that would help but but I don't
think that's typical with a lot of
single mothers that's not what I've
gathered because because you ask them
like can the dad discipline the kid as
his own so if you disagree with like he
spanks your kid you disagree with it
would you let him do it and a lot of
single mothers say no to that question
but there are a lot more single mothers
than single dads so um right because the
court system doesn't allow a lot of men
to see their children I mean women win
custody 90 of the time and there's a lot
of guys that get screwed in court and
don't get access to leave kids a lot
more I think
can I just interject in that one
um
oh see there's statistics on that but
there's also
there's a big community of men that
don't have access to their children and
they're not being recognized right and
there's a thing where you hear this a
lot you hear this a lot but it's like
there are there are stories of children
that were led to believe by their
mothers that their father left them and
they're somehow at the blue I have a
personal friend of mine for example who
was able to
regain contact with his father after
like 25 years or something or 10 or 15
years sorry minus his childhood
via my LinkedIn and then found out that
it was actually his mother
that pushed him away but he was
indoctrinated with the belief that he
was abandoned by his father so it's just
like whenever I had these these kind of
things I'm not necessarily saying that
not not all men are amazing fathers and
stuff but there's a lot of men out here
that don't have a voice and all the
focus is on the women's side of things
particular things particularly single
files because I have personal experience
of co-parenting right and
I'm not not I try not to like make too
much of a comparison between men and
women but from personal experience
women have many advantages that single
fathers would dream of having
something as basic as picking up your
child from nursery and having to be
interrogated because you're seen as a
threat because you're around it with
children
every single day for the next 15 15
years all these kind of things all add
up so I'm just saying that there's more
to it than that than just like
yeah and I agree with you should accept
because um incarceration like mass
incarceration America is mainly men so a
lot more women are forced to be single
mothers
yeah so I agree with you yeah I'm the
same from society most men in the room
right yeah
when you go into a place that has lots
of little children what do you do like
what's your first response I'm
distancing myself as much as possible
I'm saying yeah and then can you imagine
being that that man with a child
it's it's like it's a really really
challenging dialogue portrayed as like
Predators wear more often that it would
be kind of scary because you don't want
to be seen like that like you like you
want to be like loving but you also feel
restricted by how Society views you no
yeah and and I'd like to say too in the
view in the U.S up there the women
our incentivize to take away the kids
from the dad no because they're paid
more um if the dad doesn't see the kids
they're given more money from Child
Support so they're literally paid to
take away the kids from the dad
um
well I agree with that I just have to
say ladies if you're doing that that's
terrible because having a man that is
willing to be in your child's life is a
blessing if he's willing to do the right
work if you're FL if you're sleeping
you're sleeping and that's your fault as
much as I Champion my sisters and I
always want to protect women I do know
that when it comes to the relationship
between parent and child that's
something that you really shouldn't play
with and you shouldn't use that to your
advantage or to full power or for
financial gain for whatever it is you're
going to hell for that because it's your
child yeah I'm taking off that point as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible